PHILIP TAN: So when
students come into class
on their first day,
they usually expect
to walk in and start working
on their dream game right away,
and that's just not
going to happen.
They have a lot to learn.
Simply to learn about working
with their teammates--
figure out who else
is in the class
and what skills
they bring to bear.
And chances are
they haven't really
thought all that much
about the game design
that they want to make.
And usually their
very first idea,
the idea that you've been
nursing ever since high school
or something, isn't the best
idea for a single semester
project.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
Students often
want to make the big
expansive epic RPG.
We get a lot of
students who want
to make the next Legend
of Zelda-- maybe trying
to remake Skyrim
but in 2D, and they
think they're scoping it
down, but they're not.
So it's one of the
first things we're
doing-- especially the first
couple weeks of the class--
are just getting
them to understand
what is the scope of the game
development project, but also
just getting them to
understand how difficult it
is to work in a team.
How much effort an
individual needs
to put forward in order to work
efficiently as part of a team,
especially when it comes to
a creative thing like game
development and game design.
A lot of students want to
make their personal project.
And the first thing
they need to do
is realize that there are
other opinions on the team that
should be respected.
And there are some
opinions that are
going to be stronger
because there's more design
experience there.
So figuring out how
to balance those teams
is a big, big step for them
to take when they start.
SARA VERRILLI: The
biggest thing we
want them to learn
when they come in
and take the course
is how to work
as a group on a
creative project.
Almost everybody's worked
on creative project before.
People have worked
in groups before,
but working on a project where
the group together is setting
the goal and the goal is fluid.
Because, with a
creative project,
with a game design
project, what you're making
is always evolving as
you keep working on it.
And so being able to, as a
group, discuss those changes,
acknowledge those
changes, work together
to get to something that
everybody wants to work on
and everybody is
capable of working on,
and you are all capable of
getting done in the very
short amount of time you have to
work on these complex projects.
That's actually one
of our biggest goals.
PHILIP TAN: One thing
about creative projects
is there aren't right answers.
There are a lot
of different ways
that a project can go
when you are basically
just trying to create
an aesthetic experience
for the players.
And so multiple people
with different viewpoints
can all be right
at the same time.
And it's not like you're
designing a machine
to solve a specific problem,
and if the problem is solved,
you know that you've
done your job.
And this can lead to a lot of
ego and clashes and arguments
over basically something that is
already difficult to implement.
And every time you get
into those arguments,
you are actually
taking time away
from the actual
development of the game.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: We try to
give the students the tools
and methods they can use if
they have an argument to provide
evidence for the argument.
And often it comes down to
testing out ideas, rather than
having those
discussions as a team.
Using prototyping methods,
using either paper--
if they just got the paper
right there before they've even
written code.
Just throw something on paper,
get another person look at it,
and then to see,
did it work or not?
Getting away from
having the personalities
involved, getting
away from having ego
involved in all this.
For first-time designers, for
the students that we have,
if they don't have the
evidence, the first thing
they're going to go back to it
is personal ego, which is not
the way to do these things.
It will just cause further
problems down the line.
SARA VERRILLI: So
the course is overall
organized with four projects.
All of our work is group work
because we are emphasizing
how do you work
together on a team
to solve a creative problem.
All of our projects
are group projects.
And we grade
primarily as a group.
Our projects start from very
small and scale up to big.
So we have our
opening project, which
is just doing a paper
prototype-- even
a fraction of a paper
prototype-- not a full game.
It's just what are the
main actions in the game?
And that's about a
two-week project.
And then we build up to,
OK, you've got a prototype.
Form a new group, a
bigger group this time,
about double our group in
size from three to six,
and turn that into
a digital game.
For the third project, you, once
again, have that two-week time
period, but during
the second project,
we taught you our basic
project management
schemes and some
skills-- using that second
project as an example of how
to do that.
And on the third
project we're asking
you to come up with your
own game design idea,
prototype it out, and
finish it as a group using
all those project management
techniques that we taught.
It's sort of our
test run project
for the fourth project,
which is the final project.
It lasts, I think,
seven and a half weeks,
and we double the group
size again up to eight.
We are actually intentionally
giving the students
large groups that are
harder to work with.
And their first thought is
"we've got all these people,
we can make a huge project."
And our response is "you've
got all these people.
You're going to
have to figure out
how you're all going to
communicate well together,
so you can actually
get something done."
And that's sort of
the final capstone
project where we give
them a fairly tight set
of constraints.
But other than that, they
are designing the design.
They're planning out
the project management.
They're in charge of planning
their testing sessions
and their polishing sessions.
And we use that time
to check in with them
and give them feedback
along the way.
But it really is like,
OK, we've given you
the tools, time to really
practice using them.